المشهد الانتخابي المتعلق بالبرلمان
التركي في انتخابات 2023 بتركيا مسار
مختلف عن سابقيه خاصه فيما يتعلق بتاثير
التعديلات في قانون الانتخابات التي اقرها
البرلمان في ابريل الماضي ودخلت حيز
التنفيذ في مارس الماضي تلك التعديلات
تخفضت الحد الادنى المطلوب من الاصوات
لدخول الحزب السياسي للبرلمان الى سبعه في
المئه بدلا من عشره في المئه حيث تمنع
العتبه الانتخابيه اي حزب يحصل على اقل من
سبعه في المئه على مستوى البلاد من شغل
مقعد في البرلمان حتى لو جاء اولا في
دائره انتخابيه معينه يا نص التعديل
الانتخابي ايضا على ضروره ان يكون الحزب
السياسي الراغب في المشاركه بالانتخابات
قد عقد لمرتين متتاليتين مؤتمراته الكبرى
في الولايات والاقضيه فيما يتضمن القرار
تعديلا بمنع انتقال النواب من حزب الى اخر
من اجل تسهيلات الدخول في الانتخابات
في انتخابات عام 2018 انتقل 15 نائبا من
حزب الشعب الجمهوري الى حزب الخير لتمكينه
من دخول الانتخابات حيث كان قانون
الانتخابات يشترط تشكيل كتله نيابيه للحزب
داخل البرلمان مؤلفه من عشرين نائبا ليتاح
له خوض الانتخابات المقبله وبالتعديل
الجديد لن يكون ذلك متاحا في القانون
السابق كانت الاحزاب المتحالفه تتمكن من
تجاوز العتبه الانتخابيه في عموم تركيا من
خلال التحالف لكن في التعديل الاخير يتم
الحصول على مقاعده برلمانيه عن طريق
اصواتهم الانتخابيه اي انهم لن يستفيدوا
من الاصوات الزائده وبالتالي فانه لن يتم
تمثيله الاحزاب في البرلمان عبر الاصوات
الفائضه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات